heather is with us in topeka
hi heather how are you i'm doing good
how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
okay so i'm an incoming freshman at
a public university and i'm trying to
figure out how to
find fun well not necessarily find funds
but manage my money through college so
that i can
graduate that free good for you yeah
it's a great question
heather how much money do you have saved
right now
um well my parents have been saving
they've been very
very very gracious and i am so lucky to
have them
um i have quite a few different funds i
have uh cds
a mutual fund esa and a savings and
checking account
um total that is up to fifty nine
thousand dollars
um i will come
up this like coming up soon because my
car is
starting to die and i'm trying to figure
out how to cash flow
uh what's wrong with your car um
well so it's an older car it's thousand
miles on it
i mean you're cut you're cutting out
it's got how many miles on it
180 000 um
typically that's not a lot but um
we took it to the like to a
work to a shop and they said it cost
fifteen hundred
dollars to fix it so what's it worth
it's it's not worth that much okay so
you wouldn't fix it i don't
yeah so we're not fixing it so how much
does school cost
um well with
all of the scholarships i think the
first semester will cost five thousand
but that's not gonna like i'll have to
go to school for
um seven to eight years to be where i
want to become
what are you going to become either
a surgical nurse or a nurse anesthetist
so i have to get my four-year bachelor's
degree and
then go back to school for either
anesthesia or
just other certifications okay
have you mapped out what all of that is
going to cost
no um i just thought well i didn't even
really get
um how much it's going to cost this
semester starting in
10 days so i think the balance
this semester will be 5 000 but it will
um
go to the car are you are you able to
live at home and go to school
i can but um i'm in the honors program
they want me to live on campus with the
honors
students yeah i want you to too but you
don't have any money
so it's not really an option you want to
be a nurse anesthetist you don't want to
live in the honors dorm
yeah one's one's a high calling the
other one's not
so um big unless if they want to pay for
it and if you can live there for free
that's fine but i don't think that's
what they're offering is it
no it's only a 500 scholarship yeah
it but it costs you how much to live in
that dorm
um well
total cost the dorm i'm not sure
the dorm is probably with the food
meal plan is probably close to ten
thousand yeah
and so and you can save ten thousand
dollars by living at home
yes yeah done ding ding okay we just
moved that money
all right and um so you're gonna sell
your junky car
and you're going to get you a little
better junkie car but not much
better but not much better two thousand
dollar car
i mean and in case your dad and mom
aren't walking you with walking with you
on this let me tell you what kind of two
thousand dollar car to buy
ugly but
very reliable mechanically
okay so yeah that's the problem with
mine it's not
mechanically sound yeah one of my
buddies picked me up the other day to
drop me off the shop
in uh big red big red is a 1994
granada land yacht
land yacht okay 22 000
actual miles it had been sitting in his
grandmother's
garage it is pink it's not really red
because it's faded it is the ugliest
freaking car i have ever seen
and it is so reliable and it's 500 bucks
but only 22 000 miles on it now you
but you got to give a car like that a
name but you know what that name is that
name is
nurse anesthetist school you know what a
nurse anesthetist makes
i'll tell you what they make a lot a lot
300
400 grand some of them okay so
i want you to go get that school and
drive anything you want later because
you drove big red
okay and i want you to live at home so
you get that degree because you got a
great career path
but here's here's a rule when you're
setting goals and rachel and i talk
about this all the time we talk about
here
in our business all the time begin with
the end in mind
stephen covey said in his book the seven
habits of highly effective people what
that means is
you need to go ahead and lay out exactly
what we're going to do we're going to
live at home
and we're going to do this and it's
going to cost us this i think you can
get through
undergrad there for less money than you
have
okay if you live at home matter of fact
i'm positive you can
that um you can get through undergrad in
an in-state school
in state public university in oklahoma
or in kansas i'm sorry um
and um you you can get through and for
less than 60 thousand bucks
and buy a 2 000 big red yeah and i would
say heather
you don't buy big red just get you a
little black honda civic call it a day
do what you got to do dave let's talk
about the ugly car so you can find a
cheap car that's just
yeah but don't concentrate on it all
right i know people that want a little
mazda626 but
and the stupid things got 180 000 miles
on it but it's sexy for the
sexy when you're sitting on the side of
the road broken down right i think
heather i don't want heather to take you
literally
if it is big red it's great but i'm just
saying you can find a great two thousand
dollar car
that's a black on the seven that was a
five hundred dollar car
true so that's what you gotta do get you
an old car it's fine
and then you need to map out very
specifically what what this school is
going to cost you for four years
look at your esa look at the growth look
exactly what's going to happen
map out how much money if you need some
each semester
how much you need and then how many
hours you have to work to
fulfill that and then you're looking on
to to medical to medical school much
easier to work
a bazillion hours in undergrad than it
is in grad school yes
live oh live like the classic college
student yeah just broke and work
not even no don't live like you're not
playing beer pong you're working
don't you know classic classic college
student is like broke
and you are working like that's like
that's called [ __ ] you eat ramen noodles
that's what i did in college yeah you're
broke you don't have money so like
that's how you need to live because i'm
a good dad that's right
that's why you had ramen noodles in
college built character
turned you into a complaining about it
at all i'm not complaining i'm just
telling heather
you're gonna have to work and you're
gonna be broke and it's fine like that's
the time to do it you don't want to be
broke
and eating ramen noodles at 32 years old
with two kids well you don't want me to
you call me your 400 000
in debt that's right because you wanted
to be a nurse anesthetist
and um so don't you know you can do this
you're a bright young lady
this is very possible all we did was
take you through the first couple of
steps
of making decisions that cause you to
hit your goal
once you have your goal you say this is
the goal i want to graduate here i
graduate in six years six point five
years and here's a program i can do that
in and that's about really what it'll
take you
and um if uh and here's a program and
here's a less expensive program and i
gotta get qualified for that and i gotta
get scholarships and i gotta drive a
cheap car
and i gotta live at home and what has to
be true for me to be able with my 60
with my 59 000 worth of stuff what has
to be true
how much money do i have to make how
much money mom and dad ship in in
addition
mom and dad have been generous already
uh so that we hit this goal and if you
come out of school
as a nurse and this is 100 debt-free
touchdown baby touchdown
i mean the financial goals the financial
milestones you will be able to hit will
blow your freaking mind or you'll spend
the next decade cleaning up the mess
because you didn't have a plane
so you are too smart to do it the wrong
way you're gonna do it the right way you
called here
thank you for the bravery to do that i
applaud you you're a rock star
develop a detailed plan of what has to
happen
and which prices you're going to pay to
get there
and it'll be worth it you can do this